time for an update on that story we did
on that dude who got blasted after
pranking someone at the mall turns out
there's more information that came out
right there was a YouTuber just last
week that's known for pranks who was
filming out at a mall who got shot with
a YouTuber Tanner cook reportedly saying
I was playing a prank and a simple
practical joke and this guy didn't take
it very well the guy that shot him being
charged with aggravated malicious
wounding use of a firearm in the
commission of a felony and discharging a
firearm within a building while cook is
absolutely lucky he's still alive you're
the Washington Post reporting that on
Friday a top prosecutor reviewed the
video of the YouTube prankster
reportedly at that time they could not
rule out charge and cook with a crime
Cook's father reportedly responding to
this news by saying if you're going to
bring charges against my son go bring
charges against TV celebrities and prank
shows what'd I tell y'all what I tell
y'all that father's a [__] loser what
I tell y'all
so they're thinking of pressing charges
why do you think that is do you think
this person played a simple prank with
like oh I'm behind it no clearly this
man was doing something where he was
harassing the individual and the
prosecutor seen that and they're like oh
this man instigated the situation and
antagonized the individual
and the father's response is why don't
you go charge the other people see
this is what I mean parents need to hold
their kids accountable when your kids
being a little [__] disturber and going
up in people's faces and bothering them
like Listen People Too Many people are
going through terrible times too many
people got mental health issues me being
to America the amount of instability I
don't [__] seen if you think I'm
going around messing with strangers you
are bugging
this kid wanted to [__] around and he
found out want to take people's
groceries take people's hair accuse them
of diddling little kids it's just a
prank found out he landed on one person
who's just not that well people are
really suffering so when you go and you
poke in prod and you go up in their
business and they tell you to get away
and you don't
you might be the [__] last tick they
need to snap I'm not saying it's a good
thing I'm not saying it's good but
that's the reality of the world we live
in I might tell you don't walk around
the hood with your chain hanging out you
go over there you get robbed I'm gonna
say it's not a good thing but hey you're
[__] stupid
stupid that's you
[__] around keep finding out and
everybody else all the videos of people
getting punked on social media let's
make it so no one can do that anymore
the prosecutor also adding in the
footage cook approaches the shooter in
the mall's food court area gets close to
him and follows him for approximately 60
to 90 seconds [__]
he followed this person for how long
hell no
and this is why I said last time get
murked and then what I think a couple of
these people actually need to lose their
lives so that we stop seeing this kind
of [__] dumb behavior and then what
happened after you followed him he
finally approached him you know what to
make the prank a prank
and then the person had to defend
himself because it was as I seen in the
videos is Mo super insistent
ah well
to me
it's just something that happened that
was supposed to happen uh release the
other dude by the way oh you can release
him no I don't think so you can't be
shooting here about people in public
that's just no you can't do that even
when someone's father you can't like
ethically speaking I know that's wrong
how I actually feel release them release
my boy
so that's what I'm saying but I know
it's not the right thing so I wouldn't
make that yo
last time I took a plane this is what
they gave me yeah this wonderful little
bundle of joy the problem with those is
that you can't hear nothing uh it always
it's just in my ear so you know what I
mean
that's in my way what I use now when I
travel is the raycon earbuds it comes
with five different types of gel uh
there's an awareness mode there's a
noise isolating mode as well so you can
perfectly hear the sound that comes out
of those earbuds and the other
competitors far too expensive we offer
the premium sound at half the price and
not only that but they're also water
resistant yeah so it's not even just
when I travel it's when I train too it's
water resistance because I'm sweating
and everything and stuff and they don't
fall off
well look let me show you
see
where you at go to the link in the
description below or go to buy recon.com
Abba to get 15 off on us person told
cook to stop several times and tried to
walk away so he told him to stop
multiple times this [__] kept
insisting on [__] with him
he said yo leave me alone nah leave me
alone nah leave me alone all right if
you're not gonna leave me alone I'm
Gonna Make You Yank yay some of y'all
need to get blasted what I said is
I really I really I understand what the
hell you were saying before yeah he was
talking about yeah you can't shoot
people
90 seconds I'll tell you
I tell you to leave me alone I'm telling
you the traumas that is out there and
who you're messing with
if the footage comes out and it looked
different I'm gonna feel some type of
way yeah I'm saying if this was a man
following a woman and she shot him how
would y'all feel oh live your life my
girl 90 seconds is a long [__] time
to be followed by somebody you've told
stop to several times I'm just saying I
don't know what the footage is gonna
look like I might change my mind if I
see what he was doing but following
someone for 90 [__] seconds and you
have to understand one thing okay if
it's if you're making a prank you're
making it obvious and super sus
so you're making eye contact and stuff
like that you know when you walk you
know when you walk in the streets you
know when you walk in the streets and
you look in that danger or something is
about to happen you understand what I'm
saying does that happen to you you or
you look someone someone is about to
talk to you whether you're in the Metro
whatever or not and that person is a
little bit off and you know something's
about to happen what happened everyone
has that situation I understand what I'm
saying I'm talking to you my [__] yeah
I know but I'm saying I know I know I
know I'm not talking to everybody okay
not so I can't talk to everybody I'm
talking to you so you know whenever
you're walking down and then you see
there's a
what is going on why is this person like
this and why does this the sense that
you feel right here you don't know
Indianapolis after that person that
person confirms it yeah we're
approaching you and being extra stuff
yeah and then you ask them to stop and
they don't that feeling is very that's
it if and if especially if you've seen
different things if you've been
around certain people or whatever we're
not in certain situation you don't come
back from that no no it's nothing you
can't turn it off you you don't come
back from that you never turn those
instances that that hyper sensibility in
a hyper uh uh awareness you can't turn
that off so you do that hmm
bro I've avoided so many dangerous
situations just because of that because
I could tell people about the fight
someone's gonna get stabbed yeah I'm
like well you leave a club and then
after that five minutes later people run
up yeah you could you can sense that
[__] but that's because there's tension
building if you're building attention
with somebody they might not wait for
you to do something before they snap on
your ass you follow this man for 90
[__] seconds I guarantee you
you do that in the hood and you follow
somebody for 10 20 seconds and then go
[__] roll up on your ass it's gonna
be 90 seconds it's gonna be a wrap die
you can't even look at people that long
90 seconds good [__] you can't even
look at people that long some of you
guys I don't know who raised you
[__] but obviously deadbeats
like this [__] loser Dad okay you're
following someone for 90 seconds it's
like that Asian dude that took him
nothing but 20 to 30 seconds to want to
fight him you followed him after he
tried to walk away
nah you got no and there's a difference
between good pranksters and bad prices
but unfortunately the bad practices take
up so much about memory good pranksters
do stuff that don't invade your privacy
and if you're uncomfortable they just
book it afterwards and leave they don't
just be following you and harassing you
it's short and sweet the person that
stops keep it the [__] pushing
but these people were just pestering and
pushing and pushing and pushing and
pushing and doing weird [__] like taking
people's food taking their heads taking
their clothing decusing them of crimes
running up on them with knives and
getting killed
die then shooting cook in the abdomen
with the prosecutor noting you don't
know the recipient of this type of prank
where they are or what their trauma
might be they may receive it as being a
threat but also adding nothing that I am
saying absolves a shooter for what he
did but as far as how all this is going
to shake out or even with the jitian
situation we're gonna have to wait and
see and of course in the meantime I'd
love to know your thoughts yeah okay
shout out to this prosecutor because he
said the right things and he has to see
the other side of him it's like people
who instigate situations and get mad at
the reaction of people it's like bro
I'm sorry you get no sympathy for me
zero
people are dealing with enough [__]
as it is you want to go around out of
your way to go up in the bubble and when
they tell you to stop multiple times you
keep pushing them man
people are too [__] stressed out for
that kind of [__] so you guys need
to learn how to act that's what it is
not saying shooting people in
retaliation is like the greatest thing
but I also don't feel bad because 90
[__] seconds a long time being told
several times to stop is a long time and
if a woman felt half as threatened as
this man did and she's not new following
her nobody would bat an eye at that
woman
not a single person
no 90 seconds that's long
that's long that's a whole verse and a
hook
and maybe a second hook if it's a beagle
song
that's a long time
uh yeah the Rockwilder by Redman and
Method Man was two minutes and 15. boom
boom boom boom boom boom yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then Method Man goes be a hobby
easy
[Music]
microphone checkup
microphone checklist foreign
[Music]
foreign
yeah
yeah [__] these people bro yo people go
out harassing folks you can't call [__]
you I think that's okay to have that
kind of energy it's okay to say [__]
these people yeah absolutely I'm all for
people voicing their opinions being as
[__] playground as they want to be
same with it but if you getting up in
people's face 90 seconds help me and I
understand that you're like your kids
are your little sweetheart and
everything and stuff but no they could
do bad things okay if you love it and
correct them you you have to be able to
correct that's your job they do your
kids do not always do right that's
impossible even the best kid can they
gonna [__] up sometime and it's your job
to be like yo
what was that my guy
so yeah anyways let us know what you
guys think in the comments below
yeah if you love your child sometimes
you gotta discipline them or tell them
when they're wrong so you can keep them
safe in the future you enabling them
might put them in another situation
where it gets dangerous and if this kid
dies or if he goes and he gets axed okay
it's gonna be his fault but it's also
gonna be his dad's fault
because God gave me the grace of having
a second chance and instead of taking
that and learning the lesson that was
provided to him because most experiences
in life they offer good lessons you
didn't take that well listen sometimes
you might repeat the same mistake and
get a different outcome
I don't hope it for you but maybe that's
what you need
so that the world knows not to do this
kind of [__] [__] that's what I think
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you